MEMBERS THE ASSEMBLY SESSION IS
CALLED TO ORDER.
WE HAVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ACOSTA.
AGUIAR CURRY.
ALLEN.
ARAM BELA. BAKER. BERMAN.
BIGELOW. BLOOM.
BONTA. BRAVO.
BURKE. HOW THE ARROW?
CALDERONE CORREO SERVAN SAYS
CHILD.
SHAH THEN AS.
GEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY.
DALY. EGGMAN LARA. FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER
CHRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GRAY GRAY SEN HARPER HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE MON. LOW.
MAIN SHINE MATHIS
MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA. MELENDEZ MULLIN
MASUCCI THOSE ARIANE. OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON QUIRK QUIRK
SILVA RAISES RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO SOLACE SANTIAGO
STEINORTH STONE. THURMAN'S
TEEN VOGUE PILE. WALDRON WEBER
WOULD MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
MEMBERS.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER IN
THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER.
THE DAYS PAYROLL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN REVEREND
FATHER HOSTA. REVERENT.
LAST TUESDAY ON THE MORNING OF
JANUARY NINTH TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN.
NINE RELIGIOUS TRADITIONS
GATHERED FOR LEGISLATIVE
INTERFAITH PRAYER SERVICE
AT THE CATHEDRAL OF THE BLESSED
SACRAMENT ON ELEVENTH STREET.
SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN OF THAT.
OF A BAR STATUS AND STATE SENATE
CHAPLAIN OPENED THE VENT.
AND AS CHAPLAIN FOR A STATE
ASSEMBLY I WAS HONORED TO CLOSE.
AFTER THE NINE VARIOUS SPEAK
TRADITIONS SHARED A BRIEF PRAYER
OR REFLECTION.
I CLOSED WITH THESE WORDS THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU IN
OPENING OUR FLOOR SESSION TODAY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
HAVING DIVERSE RELIGIOUS
TRADITIONS COMING TOGETHER IS IN
A WAY. OUR ATTEMPT TO REFLECT
THE UNPARALLELED DIVERSITY OF
OUR TRULY UNIQUE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER EQUALLY AS IMPORTANT AS
EMBRACING DIVERSITY.
IS EMBRACING UNITY.
JOSEPH CAMPBELL OFTEN CONSIDERED
TO BE THE GREATEST AUTHORITY ON
THE MYTHS AND RELIGIONS OF
HUMANITY IN THE PAST CENTURY.
WOULD OFTEN REFER TO. THE PSYCHE
UNITY OF MANKIND.
IN OTHER WORDS THERE'S A PSYCHIC
UNITY THAT IS ROOTED. IN THE
SHARED EXPERIENCE OF ALL
HUMANKIND. TO THE WHOLE OF HUMAN
CITY.
HOLD OF HUMAN HISTORY.
REGARDLESS OF COUNTRY CULTURE
TIME OR PLACE.
WE SHARED THE EXPERIENCE OF
BEING BORN INTO A WORLD OF
CONSTANT CHANGE.
WE HAVE HOPES AND FEARS. WE KNOW
LOVE AND LOSS.
AND WE LOOK HOW DID THE UNIVERSE
IN WONDER AND ALL.
JUST OF EVERY MAN AND WOMAN WHO
HAS EVER LIVED.
AS WE EMBRACE DIVERSITY LETTUCE
ALSO EMBRACE OUR SHARED
HUMANITY.
AND MOVE FORWARD TOGETHER TO
HELP CREATE THE KIND OF WORLD WE
KNOW IN OUR HEARTS WE ALL DREAM
OF.
NOW MORE AND.
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND I INVITE YOU
TO REMAIN STANDING FOR THE FLAG
SALUTE TODAY SALUTE WILL BE
OFFERED BY SOME REMEMBER CHOI.
WHAT AN HONOR TO THE?
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
AND TO YOUR PROPERTY OR STANDS.
ONE NATION UNDER.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
THE READING THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO MONDAY DECEMBER
EIGHTEENTH TWENTY SEVENTEEN
STREETS ARE PROVISIONS OF JOINT
WILL THIRTY NINE THE FOLLOWING
IT'S ONLY DRAWS THEIR CALLED
AROUND LOOSE AND HISTORIC GIPSON
SECONDS AT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE.
INTO IT INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ IT
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
WE'RE MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
YOUR CALDERON.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER A
QUESTION ANIMUS CONSENSUS SPEND
ASSEMBLY WILL ONE EIGHTEEN NAY
TO ALLOW SOMEONE MEMBERS SHOWING
QUIRK SILVA.
TO HAVE GAS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY.
NEED UNANIMOUS CONSENT GRANTED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ALSO
REQUESTED AMHERST CONSENT TO
SUSPENDED SEVERAL FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS COMING AT ALL COOLEY
MAIENSCHEIN. RAY AS RUBIO.
TO SPEAK ON IN A GERMAN AND
MEMORY TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
ABSENCES FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROB
BONTA FOR ILLNESS AND BABIES
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ADAM GRAY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KEVIN MULLIN.
AND FOR DEFINITE FAMILY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA.
MR O'DONNELL YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GUEST INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
DELEGATES FROM.
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF%
STUDENT COUNCIL. WHO ARE UP IN
THE GALLERY SOMEWHERE?
THEY KNEW THEY COULD STAND UP.
THEIR HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT
GOVERNMENT LEADERS FROM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND THEY
ARE IN SACRAMENTO TO DEVELOP THE
LEGISLATIVE AGENDA.
THAT THEY WILL PRESENT TO THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEES TOMORROW AFTERNOON I
WILL.
THAT WITH SENATOR ALLEN.
IF YOU HAVE TIME I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO DROP BY THE
HEARING.
BASED ON THEIR PRESENTATIONS IN
PRIOR YEARS THERE THEY ARE.
I GUARANTEE THAT YOU WILL BE
IMPRESSED BY THE QUALITY OF
THEIR PROPOSALS AND THE
PROFESSIONALISM.
OF THEIR PRESENTATIONS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING CAST
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
GIVE THE MAN.
THANK YOU WE'RE MOVING TO
BUSINESS IN THE DAILY FILE.
RECONSIDERATION ITEMS FILE ITEMS
ONE THROUGH FOR OUR CONTINUED.
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE ITEM
FIVE IS PASSING RETAIN WE'RE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SIX ACR ONE
FORTY FOUR MADAM CLERK WILL YOU
PLEASE READ THE ITEM.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FORTY FOUR BY SELLING NUMBER
CHOI AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
CREATE AMERICAN DAY
RICHARD CHOI DOCTOR CHOI YOUR
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS.
IT IS ON MY HONOR TO PRESENT TO
YOU TODAY.
A YOU SEE OUR ONE HUNDRED FORTY
FOUR. WHICH WILL RECOGNIZE SUCH
JANUARY FIFTH THIRTEEN.
WITHOUT SON.
EIGHTEEN AS. KOREAN AMERICAN DAY
THIS IS A TO COMMEMORATE THE ONE
HUNDRED FIFTEEN. ANNIVERSARY OF
A KOREAN IMMIGRATION TO AMERICA.
IN NINETEEN OH THREE THE FIRST.
ONE HUNDRED TWO INDIVIDUAL
ARTISTS.
TO COME TO THE UNITED STATES ARE
FROM KOREA ARRIVED IN HAWAII.
THAT'S A PART OF THE. GROUP OVER
IMMIGRANTS OF TO WORK. ON A SHOW
PLANTATION IN HAWAII.
FROM. NINETEEN OH FOUR TO.
NINETEEN OH SEVEN.
APPROXIMATELY ONE THOUSAND MORE
ARRIVED IN SAN FRANCISCO.
THIS TIME KOREAN AMERICANS.
IMMIGRANTS SO WERE WORKING AS
SAW FARMWORKERS.
WAGE LABOR LABORERS.
FOR MINING.
COMPANIES ARE AND THE SEX ON
HAND SO ON THOUGH RATE RULES.
FOR MANY THAT THOUGH GREW UP
HERE THEY PROBABLY SERVED THIS
COUNTRY IN THE ARMED. SERVICES
ARE AND THE FOUR STAR IN THE.
WOULD WORK TOO AS JUMP MANY
CONTINUE TO A SELF TODAY.
AS OF NOW.
ABOUT THE TWO. POINT FIVE
MILLION.
PEOPLE LIVING IN THE UNITED
STATES IS TO HAVE A KOREAN
ANCESTRY.
THEY HAVE COME TO HEAR IN
PURSUIT OF THE AMERICAN DREAM.
I AM ONE OF THEM.
THEY MAKE A SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTIONS ARE IN MANY FIELDS
R. INCLUDING FINANCE.
TECHNOLOGY LAW MEDICINE
EDUCATION
SPORTS MEDIA AND ARTS.
THE MILITARY MILITARY AND THE
GOVERNMENT.
AND ALSO IT IS SO ON THIS DAY.
THAT. WE COMMEMORATE THE ARRIVAL
OF THE A FIRST ONE HUNDRED TRUE.
BRAVE US OR SUB THAT THAT CAME
TO THE UNITED STATES ARE AND THE
CELEBRATE.
THE ONE POINT A TO POINT FIVE.
MILLION OUT PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE
TODAY.
WITH DATA I ASK YOUR SUPPORT OR
OF HIS SO RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
INTENSE SPEAKER.
PEIRSOL PALMOLIVE THANK MY YA
COLLIE FROM IRVINE FOR.
OF AUTHORED THIS ACR ONE FORTY
FOUR AND JOB ARE.
MY DISTRICT IF YOU DRIVE A UP
AND DOWN THE NORTH FIRST STREET
IN THE NORTH SOUTH SAY. YOU'LL
FIND SOUND LANDMARK BUILDING
WHICH IS TO HAVE QUARTER OF SAN
SONG SURROUNDED BY MANY MANY OF
THE KOREAN A A BUSINESS LIKE A
HIGH NEXT AND SO ON AND SO
FORTH.
PROVIDING TECHNOLOGIES AND
RESEARCH NOT YOU JUST IMPROVING
OUR DAILY LIFE BUT ALSO IMPROVE
OUR.
HOUSES SERVICES AND SO ON AND
SO FORTH.
IF YOU JUST AGO GO TO MY NEXT
TOWN CITY OF SANTA CLARA EARNED
DRIVING UP AND DOWN EL CAMINO
RIALTO YOU WILL SEE A LOT OF
TOOLS THE SERVICE BUSINESS THAT
ARE OWNED AND OPERATED BY THE
FIRST GENERATION. OF KOREAN
AMERICANS IN NOT ONLY A DAY HOW
ARE WORKING HARD TO PROVIDE
SERVICES IN AND OUR A AND
NEIGHBORHOOD IN OUR AREA BUT
ALSO THE HOUSE EMPLOYEES.
EMPLOYEES THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF OUR RESIDENTS
BILLED AS A A IN IMMIGRANT
MYSELF I KNOW THE STRUGGLE ALL
BILL SERVE FIRST GENERATION
KOREAN AMERICANS.
THERE'S NEVER A YOU SEE TASK SO
MY HAT'S OFF TO ALL THOSE PEOPLE
AT THAT STARTED THE BUSINESS AND
CONTRIBUTE GREATLY. TO BECOME A
COMEY AG IN SANTA CLARA AND OR
SAN JOSE O. M. I'M VERY
PRIVILEGE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE THE CO AUTHOR.
OF FOR ACR ONE FORTY FOUR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ONE I
THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM COMEDIAN
MARKETS SHOW. NEWS
ANCHOR LISA CAN.
GOLFER JANE PARK.
SUSAN AND CUDDY THAT PRISSY MELT
BINARY OFFICER IN THE U. S.
NAVY.
JANE JOHNSON NEKA ACTIVISM AWARD
WINNING AUTHOR THESE ALL
IMPORTANT WOMEN WHO HAVE BEEN
FIRST I IN MANY RESPECTS AND
CHILL RACERS FOR SO MANY OTHER
WOMEN CURRY AND AND OTHERWISE.
AND SAYS WE RECOGNIZE THE
KOREAN AMERICAN WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE RECOGNIZE WHAT OUR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS OUT THERE
WHO HAVE DONE SO MUCH FOR OUR
STATE AND NATION. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
SILVA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE FORTY FOUR WHICH
RECOGNIZES JANUARY THIRTEENTH.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS KOREAN
AMERICAN DAY.
THIS DAY SPEAKS TO THE PROUD AND
RICH HISTORY OF PEOPLE IN SEARCH
OF OPPORTUNITY AND THE FREEDOMS
AMERICA PRESENTS TO THOSE WHO
WANT TO MAKE A BETTER LIFE FOR
THEIR FAMILIES AND CHILDREN.
IN FACT
TODAY'S RESOLUTELY RESOLUTION
SPEAKS AND SUPPORT OF ALL OF OUR
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES WHO HAVE COME
TO AMERICA TO AMERICA TO DO THE
VERY SAME THING CREATE
OPPORTUNITY. AND TO PROSPER HERE
IN AMERICA.
ORANGE COUNTY IS EMILY MATIC OF
THAT JOURNEY AS THE VAST
MAJORITY OF KOREANS IN ORANGE
COUNTY ARE FOREIGN BORN.
AS CHAIR OF THE JOBS COMMITTEE I
RECOGNIZE THE BUSINESSES SERVING
THE KOREAN COMMUNITY R. FLOOR
SHEEN AND GROWING NEARLY ONE OUT
OF FIVE BIT MEMBERS OF THE
KOREAN COMMUNITY ARE SELF
EMPLOYED. WORKING TO SECURE
THEIR FUTURES FOR THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND AGAIN AS WE
LOOK AT THIS RESOLUTION THIS
COULD BE A RESOLUTION. FOR MANY
OF OUR COMMUNITIES WHETHER IT'S
THE KOREAN COMMUNITY OUR LATINO
COMMUNITY OR MANY OTHERS ARE
STORIES ARE THE SAME. PEOPLE
COMING LONG DISTANCES TO COME TO
OUR COUNTRY TO LIVE THE AMERICAN
DREAM. KOREAN AMERICANS HAVE
BECOME AN INTEGRAL WHOLE PART OF
OUR MAINSTREAM AMERICAN SOCIETY
AND HAVE MADE IMPORTANT
CONTRIBUTIONS AS CALIFORNIANS IN
THE FIELDS OF FINANCE
TECHNOLOGY.
LAW MEDICINE EDUCATION SPORTS
AND IN FACT THEY HAVE DONE
INCREDIBLY WELL AT OUR LOCAL
SCHOOLS TO HIGH SCHOOLS AND
COLLEGES IN AS A TEACHER I HAD
MANY OPPORTUNITIES TO WORK WITH
THE KOREAN AMERICAN STUDENTS.
WHO HAVE BEEN A PLEASURE TO WORK
THE V. THEY'VE EVEN RISEN TO THE
HIGH LEVELS OF OUR ASSEMBLY
WITH?
NOT ONLY DOCTOR CHOI AS MY
COLLEAGUE BUT FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER YOUNG KIM SERVING
ON THE STATE ASSEMBLY FLOOR. I'M
PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF THIS
RESOLUTION THAT SEEKS TO CONFIRM
JANUARY THIRTEENTH AS KOREAN
AMERICAN DAY AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER MERIT
TO CHEAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I RISE AS
THE ONLY JAPANESE AMERICAN IN
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF KOREAN
AMERICAN DAY. WHILE OUR
RESPECTIVE COUNTRIES OF ANCESTRY
MAY HAVE OUR HISTORIES
BETWEEN JAPAN AND KOREA. AND
AMERICA WE ALL AMERICANS AND
THEREFORE I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS RESOLUTION FOR KOREAN
AMERICAN DAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO.
THANK YOU AND SPEAKER TODAY I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ACR
ONE FORTY FOUR.
MY DISTRICT REPRESENTS THE ONE
OF THE LARGEST UP POPULATIONS OF
KOREANS OUTSIDE OF KOREA.
AND IT'S WITH GREAT PRIDE THAT I
REPRESENT THIS AREA THIS IS AN
AREA RICH IN CULTURE.
I DOMINATED BY A BY THE PRESENCE
OF KOREAN AMERICANS.
WE OWE A GREAT DEAL THE KOREANS.
WHO BROUGHT THEIR CULTURE TO OUR
REMARKABLE CITY AND STATE AND
FOR THAT I?
I ASK YOU FOR YEARS AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER DEBATE. MIST.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TtI WOULD YOU
LIKE THEIR FIRST ROLE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS.
ARE YOU SURE I. WOULD.
APPRECIATE FIRST OF ALL FOR YOUR
KIND WORDS SO AND THE SUPPORT OF
SO MANY MEMBERS OUT THE STATE
AYE PREACHY THAT. YES ARE MADAM
SPEAKER I WOULD LIKE TO ASK ALL.
OF US WERE OR BE OPEN FOR THE
OFFICE.
THANK YOU. METACARPALS OPEN THE
ROLE.
MEMBERS.
THIS ROLES FOR COAL OFFERS FOR
THE RESOLUTION ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THIS ROLE IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE.
SIXTY FIVE CO AUTHORS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THIS ITEM ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR PLEASE SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED.
THE ITEM PASSES THANK YOU.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
DOCTOR CHOI HAS KEPT INTRODUCE
DOCTOR CHOICE YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS.
MADAM SPEAKER IN THE MEMBERS SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME I WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE US SOME GUESTS
OUT THAT WEHAVE. NOT WITH US SO
TODAY I AM PROUD TO INTRODUCE
SOME MEMBERS ARE OF THE KOREAN
AMERICAN.
COMMUNITY. OF WHO HAVE JOINED.
OF FROM ALL OVER CALIFORNIA AND.
TODAY YOU.
TO CELEBRATE TOGETHER ON THIS
SO IMPORTANT DATE ONE JUST FOR
OR. NOT IN THE REAR OF THE YEAH
CHAMBERS SO WE ARE JOINED BY. A
CHU MIN KIM DEPUTY. R. CONSUL
GENERAL FROM SOME FRANCISCO AND.
.
TAIWAN WHO ARE DEPUTY GENERAL
COUNSEL. OF VOTE LOS ANGELES
WE ARE ALSO JOINED. UP BUT IN
THE GALLERY. IDEA SEVERAL OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE KOREAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY. AND THE VARIOUS TALK
KOREAN AMERICAN ORGANIZATIONS
SO.
WOULD YOU PLEASE SUMMARIZE SO
WHERE YOU ARE SITTING.
OR THE MEMBERS SO.
FOR JOINING TODAY.
THEY ALL.
REPRESENT THAT EACH DIFFERENT
NOT DISTRICTS ABOUT THE
INCLUDING UP IN AND A KOREAN
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION SAN
FRANCISCO KOREAN AMERICAN
FOUNDATION SACRAMENTO OR. A
KOREAN AMERICAN FOUNDATION
KOREAN AMERICAN NOW FOUNDATION.
OF THEY HAVE JOINED US TODAY TO
RECOGNIZE THE YEAH OUR AND US
CELEBRATE OF THIS A HISTORIC
DAY.
MEMBERS UP PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THEM AND I INVITE ALL
OF YOU LATER IN THAT ROOM THIRTY
ONE SEVEN FOUR WELCOMING
RECEPTION UPON ADJOURNMENT OF
THIS SESSION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR
AB SIX.
HE WON THE MOAN.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
AS UNABLE SIXTEEN SIXTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOME REMEMBER THE
MOUND.
SOME MEMBERS AMONG.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY ONE AMENDMENT AT
THE DESK WILL DELETE MUCH OF THE
CURRENT CONTENTS AND AREN'T
INTENDED TO SIMPLY MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. TO PORTIONS
OF THE EDUCATION CODE THE DEAL
WITHOUT DAY OUTDATED FEDERAL
PERMISSION ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THESE AMENDMENTS.
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS BUDDHISTS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE WE
FIFTY FOUR.
I WON OPPOSED.
THAT MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED AND
THE AMMO OF THE MEMBERS ARE OUT
AND.
WILL BE.
OUT IN PRINT AND BACK ON FILE.
ITEM NINE PASSING RETAIN ITEM
TEN AB SIX SO EIGHT BY IRWIN THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX OH EIGHT BY
SOME A MEMBER IRWIN AND ACTUALLY
TO CONSUMER CREDIT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WHEN YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I AM PRESENTING EIGHTY SIX SO
EIGHT WHICH PROHIBITS THE
CHARGING OF FEES TO PROTECTED
CONSUMERS WHO WANT OF PLACES
SECURITY FREEZE ON THEIR CREDIT
REPORT.
THIS MEASURE IS IN RESPONSE TO
THE EQUIFAX DATA BREACH WHICH
EXPOSED THE PERSONAL INFORMATION
OF A HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
AMERICA HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
MILLION. AMERICANS DUE TO THE
POOR CYBER SECURITY MEASURES IN
PLACE.
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO BAY OF PAY A PREMIUM TO
BE PROTECTED FROM THE MISUSE OF
THEIR CHILDREN'S PERSONAL
INFORMATION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
SIGNAL QUESTIONS ARE DEBATE THE
CLICK OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE SIXTY
FOUR I.
NO OPPOSED.
THE MOTION PASSES.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING BACK TO ITEM EIGHTY BE
TEN FORTY ONE LEVINE MCCORKLE
READ. AT SOME LEVEL TEN FORTY
ONE BY SOME A MEMBER LEVINE AND
ACTUALLY THE TRANSPORTATION.
WHICH WILL BE NO RECOGNIZE THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER TODAY ARE
PRESENTING AB TEN FORTY ONE
WHICH WILL CLARIFY WHO MAY SERVE
AS A REPRESENTATIVE ON THE OR
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE CREATED BY
S. B. FIVE NINETY FIVES REGIONAL
MEASURE THREE.
THIS BILL WILL PROTECT OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE FROM HAVING A
MEMBERSHIP THAT COULD HAVE
IMPROPER RELATIONSHIPS
INFLUENCING THEIR JUDGMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
SENIOR DEBATER DISCUSSION THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROAD.
I SIXTY ONE.
NO ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM ELEVEN PASS AND RETAIN.
I AM TWELVE AB IT SEVENTY LEVINE
THE CORPOREAL.
AS I WILL EIGHT SEVENTY BY PHONE
NUMBER LEVINE AND ACTUALLY TO
PRISONERS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB EIGHT SEVENTY
ALLOWS JUDGES TO MAKE A
RECOMMENDATION TO CDC ARE THAT A
DEFENDANT RECEIVED A MENTAL
HEALTH EVALUATION YOU MAY RECALL
LAST YEAR THE ASSEMBLY PASSED
THE SEVENTY SEVEN DOES THAT.
BUT THE GOVERNOR VETOED IT
UNFORTUNATELY HE DIDN'T READ THE
STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT THAT SAID
THAT THE CORRECTIONS OFFICIALS
HAVE BEEN FAILING TO ENSURE.
THAT PRISON STAFF MEMBERS
PROPERLY EVALUATE AND TREAT
PRISONERS MENTAL HEALTH LET'S
GIVE THE GOVERNOR ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO SIGN THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SEEN NO DEBATE OR
QUESTIONS.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE TELLING THE VOTES.
I SIXTY SIX NY ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES.
ITEMS THIRTEEN THROUGH FIFTEEN
PASS AND RETAIN. MOVING TO ITEM
SIXTEEN AB SIX SIX SIX O'CLOCK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SIX
THE SIX BY FAMILY MEMBER AGUIAR
CURRY AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
ELECTIONS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR CURRY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB SIX SIX SIX IS
INSPIRED BY THE CONFUSION ALL OF
US THAT REPRESENT MULTIPLE
COUNTIES EXPERIENCE EVERY
ELECTION.
ALL EXPLAINED WOULD AB SIX SIX
SIX ACTUALLY DOES.
IN DISTRICT FOUR OO SIX COUNTIES
WE HAVE SIX DIFFERENT FORMS TO
FILL OUT SUBMIT. AND SIX
DIFFERENT WAYS TO SUBMIT ALL OF
THAT PAPERWORK.
THIS BILL IS A STEP TOWARD
STREAMLINING THE OVERWHELMING
ELECTIONS FILING PROCESS FOR NEW
IN NOVICE CANDIDATES. WHO ARE
UNFAMILIAR WITH THE COMPLICATED
STEPS TO QUALIFY FOR THE BALLOT?
IN THE ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE AB SIX SIX SIX PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NO OPPOSITION.
I'M CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS SECRETARY OF
STATE AND LOCAL REPRESENTATIVES
TO HAVE A STANDARDIZED PROCESS
THAT WORKS FOR ALL OF US.
REGARDLESS OF PARTY BACKGROUND
OR RESOURCES.
YOU WILL PROBABLY SEE THIS BILL
AGAIN THANK YOU ASK YOU FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO DEBATER DISCUSSION
MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TELLING THE VOTES I
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THE MOTION
PASSES.
MOVING TO SENATE THIRD READING
ITEM SEVENTEEN THROUGH TWENTY
PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS WHERE NOW MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS IN A GERMAN TO
MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A JOURNEY MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
FOR THE GERMAN MEMORIES
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. I RISE
TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
CONSENSUAL CRUISE BY THE OUT A
LONGTIME RESIDENT OF CASTOR BILL
IN MONTEREY COUNTY WHO IS WIDELY
KNOWN FOR A LIFETIME OF CIVIL
RIGHTS WORK IN ACTIVISM.
BORN IN MEXICO CITY THE NOT THE
SECOND OF NINE CHILDREN MISTER
BY THE I ARRIVED IN MONTEREY
COUNTY WITH HIS FAMILY IN
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE WHEN HE WAS
EIGHTEEN.
HE MARRIED AND HE LEFT WITH HIS
WIFE IN HOUSING PROVIDED BY
DRISCOLL'S BERRIES WHERE THEY
BOTH WORKED PICKING.
STRAWBERRIES IN THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES MISTER BY THERE WAS
HIRED AS A COMMUNITY RELIES ON
WORKER BY THE CASTRO HEAD START
PROGRAM. DURING THAT TIME HE HE
HE BEGAN TO TAKE NIGHT CLASSES
AT HARTNELL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDYING CRIMINAL LAW.
HE WAS EVENTUALLY HIRED TO WORK
AS AN INVESTIGATOR AT THE
MONTEREY COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR FOUR WHERE HE
WORKED UNTIL I RETIRED TWENTY
FIVE YEARS LATER. BUT THE WORK
THAT HAD THE GREATEST IMPACT
WITH HIS VOLUNTEER WORK ON
BEHALF OF THE LATINO FARM WORKER
COMMUNITY.
FOR CENTER BY THE A WAS A
PIONEERING CIVIL RIGHTS ACTIVIST
AND IN NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO HE
FOUNDED THE NORTH. MONTEREY
COUNTY CHAPTER OF THE LEAK OF
LATIN AMERICAN UNITED LATIN
AMERICAN CITIZENS AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION FOR CIVIL RIGHTS.
MR BY THE F. SUPPORTED SAYS THAT
CHAVEZ AND THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS IN THEIR FIGHT FOR
UNIONIZATION AND HE LED THE
EFFORTS TO MOVE FROM AT LARGE
ELECTIONS TO DISTRICT ELECTIONS
WHICH PROVIDED THE OPPORTUNITY.
FOR MINORITY COMMUNITIES OF.
COLOR TO ELECT REPRESENTATIVES
OF THEIR CHOICE HIS LIFE WAS
DEDICATED TO HELPING THOSE IN
THE COMMUNITY OF LITTLE MEANS
AND WHO WERE THE UNDERDOGS.
IN HIS RELENTLESS PURSUIT OF
JUSTICE HE WORKED TO FREE
LAURENZO PNEUMONIAS WHO SPENT
SIX YEARS IN PRISON FOR A CRIME
HE DID NOT COMMIT. HE WAS
EXONERATED THANKS TO MISTER BY
THE US TIRELESS PURSUIT OF THE
FACTS.
BUT THERE WERE COUNTLESS TIMES
WHEN MR BY THE OF PASSION FOR
DEFENDING DIDN'T MAKE THE
HEADLINES HE WAS KNOWN TO TAKE
IN FAMILIES HE FOUND WITHOUT
SHELTER AT THE COURTHOUSE. AND
RECEIVE PHONE CALLS ASKING FOR
HELP ALL HOURS OF THE DAY. HE
STOOD UP FOR THOSE WHO HAD NO
VOICE AND HIS PASSION FOR
HELPING OTHERS IS ROOTED IN HIS
HEART.
MR BY THE OF MOST IMPORTANT
LEGACY HOWEVER WAS HIS
DEDICATION TO HIS FAMILY. HIS
CHILDREN REFER TO HIM AS AN
AMAZING FATHER. AND HUSBAND A
MAN WHO GAVE SO MUCH LOVE AND
SUPPORT.
MR BY THE AYE IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE OF SIXTY YEARS METHOD IS BY
THE AYE FOR CHILDREN MARY ELLEN
AND NON THIS ONE WAY BY THE AYE
RATE BY THE A AND MY MOTHER THE
CHAPTER ABOUT THE AYE. TWELVE
GRANDCHILDREN TEN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN AND SEVEN SIBLINGS
HE WAS AN AMAZING ROLE MODEL FOR
HIS FAMILY AND THE COMMUNITY ANY
PAVE THE WAY FOR SO MANY OTHERS
HAS LIKE A LEGACY WILL LIVE
FOREVER.
I ASK THAT WE GET A DURING HIS
MEMORY.
THANK YOU SOME AMERICA BUREAU.
MEMBERS WHERE BRIEFLY MOVING
BACK TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
MR CALDERON. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY WILL
FIFTY SIXTO ALLOW THE
PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE TO NOTICE
THE FOLLOWING BILLS. FOR THEIR
HEARING ON THURSDAY JANUARY
EIGHTEENTH PENDING WE REFERRAL
FROM THE REVENUE AND TAXATION
COMMITTEE S. B. FIVE FIFTY A
GLAZER AN SCA NINE BY.
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
OVER THE ORDER. MOVING BACK TO
ATTORNEY MEMORIES.
MR COOL YOUR RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
TURN A MEMORY.
COLLEAGUES I AM HONORED TODAY
TO.
ASKED WE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF.
SOMEONE WHO PLAYED A VITAL ROLE
IN THE LIFE OF THE CAPITAL FORM.
MANY DECADES HONESTLY.
JOSE LUIS RAMIREZ.
IT IS OFTEN THE CASE THAT WE.
REMEMBER SINGULAR PERSONALITIES
FOR MANY DIFFERENT COMPLIMENTS.
JOSE LUIS ROMERO STANDS OUT
BECAUSE WITH HIS DESK WE CLOSE A
CHAPTER.
IN THE LAW OR OF THE CAPITAL
COMMUNITY.
YOU GO BACK A LONG TIME AGO
THERE WERE THREE PROMINENT
RESTAURATEURS HERE.
SERVE SACRAMENTO DOWNTOWN LONG
BEFORE WE WERE THE FOOD AND FOR
CAPITAL.
IT WAS MISTER ELLIS WHO HAD A
RESTAURANT BY THAT NAME ALICE'S
IN THE BASEMENT.
OF THE BUILDING CONNECTED THE
PARKING STRUCTURE.
AT TEMPTED EL.
FRANK FATS A COURSE.
HIS OWN RESTAURANT THERE
BETWEEN SEVENTH AND EIGHTH ON
AL.
AND THE POSIES RESTAURANT.
ACT TENTH.
OR ELEVENTH THAT NO.
WAS A.
FAME TO CAPITAL HANGING.
AND JOSE LUIS RAMIREZ ACTUALLY
STARTED.
IN SACRAMENTO AS A BUSBOY.
POSEY'S.
I CAME THE FAVORITE BARTENDER AT
POSEY'S FOR MANY MANY YEARS.
WHICH MEANS HE WAS SORT A
PRIMITIVE SECRETS OF THIS
BUILDING BECAUSE.
POSING AS HOST OF A CLUB KNOWS
THE DERBY CLUB.
THAT WOULD HAVE A TUESDAY LUNCH.
AND ALL LAWMAKERS AND LOBBYISTS
WOULD GO HAVE LUNCH IS APART THE
DERBY CLUB EACH TUESDAY.
AND JOSE WAS THEIR FAVORITE
PARTS IN.
SO HE WOULD HANG OUT WITH THEM
HE VISION BECAME THE MANAGER AND
OWNER OF POSIES.
IT'S INTERESTING TO ME ALSO AS
WE REMEMBER HIM AND HIS LIFE IN
HIS INTERTWINING WITH THE
CAPITAL COMMUNITY.
A HE GOT TO ENJOY SOMETHIN THE
FATHER NEVER GOT TO ENJOY.
HOOK JOSE LOST HIS DAD WHEN HE
WAS QUITE YOUNG.
SO HIS DAD NEVER SAW HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
OVER THE COURSE OF HIS LONG
LIFE.
TO THE CONTRARY MISTER JOSE LUIS
ROMERO IS ACTUALLY WAS ABLE TO
SEE HIS DAUGHTERS.
AND TO SEE THEM PROSPER TO WHOM
ACTUAR PROMISE BUILDING.
MARY REMEMBERS I KNOW FROM MY
EARLY CAREER HERE.
AND THEN SIERRA REP REMEMBERS
JIRO WHO WAS CHIEF OF STAFF TO
JOHN PARADES.
SO HE WAS ABLE TO WATCH HIS
DAUGHTERS.
IN A COMMUNITY THAT HE HAD AN
INTIMATE GLIMPSE INTO BECAUSE OF
HIS WORK. RISE TO LEADERSHIP
RESPONSIBILITY AND A HIGH ESTEEM
INDEED TO BE A.
SHE FOR STAFF WAS SPEAKER.
ARM AND HIS LIFE AFTER LOSING
HIS DAD THAT EARLY DATE.
YOU CAN THE EMBODIMENT OF HARD
WORK STARTED WORK AT AGE SIX.
WAS WHEN HE GOT HIS FIRST JOB.
HIS CHILDHOOD HOME WAS IN
GUADALAJARA THAT'S WHERE HE MET
HIS WIFE LAURA.
AND ESTABLISHED OUR.
LIFELONG RELATIONSHIPS WITH
WADDLE IN GUADALAJARA IN HIS
PART OF MEXICO WHERE HE GREW UP.
BUT IN NINETEEN FIFTY ONE AT THE
AGE OF EIGHTEEN HE HOPPED ON A
TRAIN HEADED TO CALIFORNIA
LOOKING TO PROSPER HIS LIFE.
AND SU PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR HIS
FAMILY AT HOME.
I HE EVENTUALLY ESTABLISHES
ROUTES HERE INSTRUCTORS I
DESCRIBE.
OPPOSE HIS RESTAURANT.
AND.
.
SO THROUGH THIS LIFE OF INTIMATE
INVOLVED WITH LAWMAKERS ARE
CROSSED A LONG LONG TIME
OF THE INSTITUTION.
HE RAISED HIS KIDS TO THE SAME
ETHIC OF HARD WORK.
COMMITMENT TO THE WELL BEING OF
OTHERS.
AND EMPATHY FOR OTHERS
IRRESPECTIVE OF BACKGROUND.
SKILL HE NO DOUBT LEARNED AS A
BARTENDER SERVER WHOEVER CAME IN
THE DOOR.
.
THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE HE WAS AN
AVID TRAVELER. MUSIC LOVER.
A COMMITTED CATHOLIC AS ONE
MIGHT
S. BACKED.
AND A CULINARY CRITIC.
BUT HIS ABIDING PASSION WAS JUST
CELEBRATED LIFE ENJOYMENT AND
COMPANY OF OTHERS.
JOSE IS SURVIVED BY HIS FAMILY
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA MEXICO.
INCLUDING HIS THREE LOVING
DAUGHTERS MARRY SARAH AND METAL
LOSE.
HIS GRAND ME HOSTAGE LIZA LARA
AND JENNER.
AND HIS GRANDCHILDREN TAYLOR
HARRISON CARTER.
AND AS WE ADJOURN HIS MEMORY
TODAY THIS IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
CAPITAL LIFE OVER DECADES.
ARE THE FAMILY ASKED WE SPEND
TIME WITH THE PEOPLE WHO HOLD
DEAR. TAKEN TIME TO EAT DRINK.
ENJOY LIFE AND MAKE A TOAST TO
IN DURING FRIENDSHIPS LIFELONG
AND BEYOND.
AND I THINK YOU FOR JOINING IN
THE MEMORY OF JOSE.
LUIS RAMIREZ TODAY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN YOUR
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER JOANNE
MARGARET THOMAS A LIFELONG
SENIOR AGAIN AND LOVING MOTHER
AND GRANDMOTHER PASSED AWAY ON
NOVEMBER FIRST TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AT THE AGE OF SEVENTY FOUR.
A GRADUATE OF KEARNY HIGH SCHOOL
AND A RESIDENT OF MIR MESA.
JOANNE WORKED FOR TWENTY YEARS
AT THE SCENE DIEGO VA HOSPITAL
SERVING MILITARY VETERANS
DOCTORS NURSES AND
ADMINISTRATORS.
HAPPILY MARRIED TO JOHN CURRY
THOMAS THE SECOND FOR FIFTY
YEARS
JOANNE AND JOHN HAD TWO
BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN DAUGHTER
KATHY JO AND SON JC THE THIRD.
AND IT SERVED AS A SECOND MOTHER
TO OUT MY STAFF MEMBER ROB
KNUTSON.
IN ADDITION TO HER HUSBAND AND
CHILDREN JOANNE LEAVES BEHIND
HER DAUGHTER IN LAW SHANNON
THOMAS HER SON IN LAW ANTHONY
HALLSTATT. AND GRANDCHILDREN AJ
JOS CHLOE AND CONNOR JOANNE WAS
LAID TO REST ON NOVEMBER TWENTY
FIRST TWENTY SEVENTEEN AT
MIRAMAR NATIONAL CEMETERY AND
WILL FOREER WATCH OVER THE CITY
AND PEOPLE THAT SHE LEFT.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAAS YOU
RECOGNIZE HERE TURN A MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
TODAY I RISE TO JOURNEY THE
MEMORY OF MY DEAR FRIEND TO GET
US YOUNGER GOMEZ.
THE VETERAN.
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER NEWSPAPER
PUBLISHER AND COMMUNITY
ACTIVIST.
GUS YOUNG NOR GRASSY IS WHO
SOMETIMES CALLED HIM.
WAS BORN IN NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR
TO MEXICAN IMMIGRANTS
IN WILMINGTON CALIFORNIA. BUT AS
A BOY HE AND HIS FAMILY MOVED TO
REDLANDS FORTY ATTENDED
SEGREGATED NORTH SIDE SCHOOLS.
DURING THE EARLY PART OF HIS
LIFE BECAUSE HE ON THE SPENT
TIME TAKING CARE HIS THREE
YOUNGER BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
TEACHING THEM IN BOTH ENGLISH
AND SPANISH.
ALL WHILE HELPING HIS FATHER
PICK ORANGES.
AND PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE FORCE
FAMILY.
S. FATHER DIED WHEN HE WAS
TWELVE YEARS OLD PLACING HIM AS
A PRIMARY CARETAKER.
OF HIS HOUSEHOLD ALONGSIDE WITH
HIS MOTHER.
EVEN AS A YOUNG MAN GOING TO
SEATTLE UNDERSTOOD THE
IMPORTANCE OF SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
THAT IT WAS THAT IT WAS CRITICAL
THAT YOU GIVE BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY MORE THAN YOU TOOK
FROM THAT COMMUNITY.
WHAT IS JAPANESE WHEN JAPANESE
FAMILIES WERE INTERNED DURING A
PRESIDENTIAL EXECUTIVE ORDER IN
NINETEEN FORTY TWO? PLUS YOU
KNOW HELP HIS INTERNED FRIENDS
BY MAINTAINING.
THEIR HOMES WHILE THEY WERE AWAY
UPON HIS GRADUATION FROM HIGH
SCHOOL IN NINETEEN FORTY THREE
GUS YANO WAS DRAFTED INTO THE
ARMY AIR CORPS DURING WORLD WAR
TWO.
AND SERVED THROUGH THE END TO
THE CONFLICT IN NINETEEN FORTY
SIX.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW.
MANY OF OUR VETERANS OF COLOR.
WHO AFTER WORLD WAR TWO?
RETURNED TO THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THEY WERE NOT A CREEK THEY WERE
NOT RECEIVED WITH OPEN ARMS.
THEY EXPERIENCED DISCRIMINATION
ACROSS MULTIPLE SECTORS
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
EDUCATION EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING.
THIS WAS NO DIFFERENT FOR GUS
JANO AND MANY MEXICAN AMERICAN
VETERANS JUST LIKE HIM.
GUS YANO DESPITE HIS OBSTACLES
PERSEVERED.
USING AS GI BILL BENEFITS TO
BECOME THE FIRST MEMBER OF HIS
FAMILY TO BECOME A HOMEOWNER.
AND PROFESSIONALLY.
WORK AS A DATA PROCESSING
OPERATOR AT BOTH NORTON AIRFORCE
BASE.
AND WITH THE COUNTY OF SAN
BERNADINO.
UPON HIS RETURN TO HIS COMMUNITY
GUS JANA WAS MOVE TO DO WHAT HIS
PARENTS HAD TAUGHT HIM TO DO.
PRIORITIZE COMMUNITY THROUGH
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY.
HE MOVED TO DIVORCE IN NINETEEN
FIFTY EIGHT. WHERE THROUGH HIS
INVOLVEMENT WITH EDUCATION AND
HIS SIX CHILDREN?
BECAME PTA PRESIDENT OF THE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
THIS OPERATED AS A LAUNCH INTO
VARIOUS FORMS OF COMMUNITY
ACTIVISM.
THE CONTINUED TO HAVE A STRONG
IMPACT.
ON HIS COMMUNITY AND MY
COMMUNITY TO THE STATE.
GUS JANA WAS A STEADFAST VOCAL
ADVOCATE OF COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
DURING THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT.
HE ANOTHER MEXICAN AMERICAN
ACTIVISTS CHALLENGE PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTOR EMPLOYERS TO
REMOVE DISCRIMINATORY BARRIERS
AND PROVIDE GREATER
OPPORTUNITIES TO WORKERS.
PARTICULARLY IN EDUCATION.
HE WAS THE FIRST ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF LUCK ON BETA GONE
FOR THAT US YAWN.
A GROUP OF MEXICAN AMERICAN
ORGANIZATIONS
WHICH EMPOWERED UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES.
HE WAS APPOINTED TO THE SALMON
DEAL UNIFIED SCHOOL BOARD OF
EDUCATION IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
ONE BECOMING THE FIRST MEXICAN
AMERICAN ELECTED TO THE SCHOOL
BOARD. WHERE HE HELPED?
LEAD EFFORTS TO INTEGRATE
SAME SEGREGATED SCHOOLS HE
ATTENDED AS A YOUNG BOY.
HE FOUNDED TO THE INLAND EMPIRE
HISPANIC NEWS ORGANIZATION IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN.
S. FIRED BY EFFORTS TO EMPOWER
AND SHINE A POSITIVE LIGHT ON
MEXICAN AMERICANS IN HIS
COMMUNITY.
HE WORKED AS THE PAPER'S EDITOR
AND PUBLISHER WITH NO PRIOR
EXPERIENCE IN THE NEWS BUSINESS.
THE PAPER THEN BECAME ONE OF THE
LARGEST CIRCULATED MINORITY
ENGLISH LANGUAGE NEWSPAPERS IN
THE ON EMPIRE. RUNNING FOR
TWENTY THREE YEARS AND WINNING
MULTIPLE AWARDS.
COLLEAGUES I COULD CONTINUE FOR
DAYS TELLING YOU THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF THIS
COMMUNITY ICON.
HE'S RECEIVED OLDER OVER NINETY
CONGRESSIONAL STATE COUNTY CITY
AND ORGANIZATIONAL RECOGNITIONS.
AND HAD RECENTLY IN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL NAMED AFTER HIM.
IN HIS HONOR IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN.
BUT I SANTA WAS MORE FOCUSED ON
THE NUMBER OF LIVES HE TOUCHED.
RATHER THAN THE AWARDS HE
RECEIVED.
THIS WILL ULTIMATELY BE WHAT
HIS.
WHAT HE IS MEASURED BY?
COUNTLESS INDIVIDUALS INCLUDING
MYSELF.
WERE FOREVER IN HIS DEBT FOR THE
PATH HE PAVED AND THE
INSPIRATION HE CONTINUES TO
PROVIDE.
EVEN AFTER HIS DEATH.
GRASSY IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
TRINI GOMEZ FOR CHILDREN TWO
STEP CHILDREN EIGHT
GRANDCHILDREN.
SORRY A GRANT GREAT GRAND
CHILDREN.
AND SEVEN GREAT GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN.
THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR YOUR
ATTENTION PLEASE JOIN ME IN
MORNING THAT I SEE ON THOSE
PASSING.
CELEBRATING HIS LIFE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER S.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ARE GOOD
AFTERNOON.
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE IN HONOR
OF THE LIFE OF MY MARVIN JOE
SITE SHE A RESIDENT OF OUR MONEY
AND A LONGTIME CONTRIBUTOR TO
OUR COMMUNITY.
I FIRST MET MARVIN ABOUT TWENTY
ONE YEARS AGO WHEN I HAD THE
HONOR OF SERVING ON THE BALLOT
COUNTY WATER DISTRICT. WHILE HE
SERVED ON THE UPPER THANK YOU
PROVOKE MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
I WILL ALWAYS REMEMBER MARVIN AS
A KIND MAN WHOSE PASSION WAS
ABOUT WATER. ISSUES AND HIGHLY
REGARDED FIRST FOR HIS EXPERTISE
ON WATER AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
THANKS TO THE MANY HATS HE WORE
THROUGHOUT HIS LIFETIME AS A
MARINE A HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER A
LAWYER AND AN ELECTED OFFICIAL.
MARVIN WITHOUT A DOUBT TOUCH THE
LIVES OF MANY.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF
TWENTY NINE YEARS SUSAN LARSEN
FLIGHTY AND HIS CHILDREN REBEKAH
FIGHT SHE AND. IDLING JOSEPH'S
HYGIENE.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY I OFFER MY
CONDOLENCES TO THE SURVIVING
FAMILY MEMBERS AND MANY FRIENDS
OF MARVIN JUST IT AS WE DURING
IN HIS MEMORY TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO.
MEMBERS LAST SUNDAY WAS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER IS
BIRTHDAY PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WISHING HIM A VERY HAPPY
BIRTHDAY.
I BELIEVE THAT LIKE ME HE IS
THIRTY NINE
AGAIN.
ADDITIONALLY MEMBERS.
I HAVE TO ANNOUNCED THAT H. R.
SEVENTY ONE HAVE YEAR WILL BE
HEARD JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
TOMORROW.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS WEDNESDAY CHAIR A
JANUARY SEVENTEENTH CHECK IN
SESSION THURSDAY JANUARY
EIGHTEENTH FLOOR SESSION AT NINE
AM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED AND RETAINED ALL
MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING IN HERE THERE NO FURTHER
BUSINESS ARE READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR CALDERON AYE MOVES TO MISTER
DALI SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
JANUARY EIGHTEENTH THE HARM
COLLEGE LIFTED